the most points that can be scored in a
game of Scrabble in a single move is
unknown but the highest so far
discovered was found by Dan wood in
2008. it requires an unlikely scenario
in which you have these seven letters
the board looks like this and it's your
turn first you take your o and turn
pacifying into o pacifying you take your
X to change is into size which means
more than one's eye you make
re-qualified pre-qualified rain washing
becomes brainwashing awakeners becomes
awakeners one time becomes Zone time and
finally with your ejaculating becomes
ejaculating you made those seven words
by vertically playing
oxyfinbutazone a word that like all the
words on this board are allowed in
tournament play by the North American
Scrabble Players Association in that one
move you scored
1780 points